así
ya deben de tener un poco de experiencia
en calcular puntos en parábolas usando
las fórmulas que escribí en el vídeo
anterior estas fórmulas están basadas en
la hipótesis de que todas estas
relaciones están en la misma proporción
y esa proporción es gobernada por t pero
ahora vamos a probar que estas fórmulas
son correctas entonces voy a usar esta
versión del interactivo y ustedes
tendrán la oportunidad de experimentar
con este interactivo en un momento y
como antes tengo una línea de
construcción que es controlada por el
parámetro t y conforme muevo tema atrás
y adelante la línea de construcción se
mueve atrás y adelante el método que voy
a usar para encontrar en donde se da el
punto de intersección parece un poco
confuso al principio pero es el método
más simple que conozco lo que haré es
introducir otra línea de construcción
pero esta vez controlada por el
parámetro s y lo que voy a hacer es
escribir una expresión para este punto
de intersección de aquí el punto de
verde
porque haría eso bueno la razón es que
observen lo que ocurre conforme ese ítem
se acercan cada vez más y más
entonces si hago que ese y t se acerquen
observa lo que pasa con el punto de
intersección
ok se mueve y observa que se acepta cada
vez más y más la parábola y justo cuando
ese es igualdad el punto de intersección
queda exactamente en la parábola
entonces si puedo escribir una fórmula
para decir en dónde está el punto de
intersección puedo calcular exactamente
en donde se da el punto de intersección
con la parábola y probablemente este es
un buen momento para poner pausa y
dejarlos que experimenten con este
interactivo y así obtengan inclusión
para lo que haremos de manera algebraica